tout va
chaison sporting de delson comme dans de
nombreux teams l'alimentation c'est
eugène forte en gras a beaucoup
d'adeptes ya tellement de choses qui se
disent ou aux comptes ou manu tu le sais
tu souhaitais et ces rapts mais ça
fonctionne pour tous alors c'est plus un
mouvement c'est plus un mode de vie
clinquant que nos jambes et je mange
plus de grolles et les gens sont ils me
regardent norma mais non c'est plus des
bons gros est des noirs des avocats
voici une assiette pourrait représenter
près bien représentant d'une des sept
agences étaient issus du porc sans
antibiotiques
on a des brocolis des poires des
poivrons verts y en a des avocats dans
ce régime les glucides ou li sucre ne
doivent constituer que 5 à 15 % des
calories consommées dans la journée les
lipides les gras de 75 à 80% ce qui se
produit c'est que les cellules du foie
commenceront à fabriquer des corps
cétoniques une sorte de carburant
secours pour pallier à l'absence de
glucose de sucre quant aux protéines
elles doivent être consommés en quantité
modérée
il y a un an l'entraîneur yann joseph
lui propose un plan alimentaire
on a commencé à éliminer des trucs de
mon alimentation tous les jours que ce
soit les sucres que ce soit les céréales
les farines commence par pays on entend
souvent parler patates par les trois
premiers mots étaient pas dit s'il parce
que le ton quand et comment un manque de
sucre qui cherchent en énergie donc en
cherchant l'énergie qui trouve pas de
sucre pour le transformer en énergie
mais ils vont aller chercher un gros
mélissa quirion s'entraîne depuis quatre
ans et adhérer okito à l'alimentation
cétogène depuis quelques mois c'est
difficile parce que je suis habituée de
manger des fruits
ce plan là on n'a pas le droit de suite
donc cet été quand il faisait chaud vous
avez envie de manger un ballon d'aubin
on a on a viré de bord pour des
selleries puis des confections mes
enfants ont embarqué les matins on se
prend des déchets que c'est super bon la
banane beurre de pinottes avec du lait
d'amande 1,9 en mêlant cheikh un petit
peu de protéines le quai tôt et très
tendance vous pouvez commander de la
nourriture en ligne vous voulez des
recettes la famille et on vous en
propose
s'il ya même médecin de famille qui a co
écrire guide pour perdre du poids en
mangeant du gras vous êtes à la
recherche de kétou coach plusieurs
offrent leurs services sur le web ce qui
va se passer dans ton corps c'est que
s'ils vont commencer à utiliser le gros
comme énergie nutritionniste en chef
chez nautilus plus alice fontaine
prépare aussi des plans l'iman terre
quand j'attaque tu adhères indienne ou
un des habitudes alimentaires
il faut que ce soit à long terme donc
fausse pose la question est ce que pour
moi c'est réaliste plus jamais mangé des
portes ou plus jamais manger des
glucides ou pour moi c'est tout réaliste
plus margée degroof selon les diètes il
est trop tôt pour confirmer certaines
hypothèses allaient fixe le régime
pourrait contribuer au renversement de
plusieurs maladies chroniques comme le
diabète de type 2 on ne peut vivre
démontrer à long terme c'est quoi les
risques mais ce qu'on peut voir à court
terme les choses que nous on aime un peu
moins commissionné sais que tu as mangé
moins de fibres
on sait que les films c'est vraiment
important pour tout ce qui est
cardiovasculaires on sait également car
des carences en circulant dans le
moindre fruit et légumes non c'est sûr
qu'on n'a pas d'études à long terme mais
quand même à court terme ont beaucoup
d'éléments qui sont vraiment importantes
dans exils
saine à long terme l'orage pas les
objectifs ont été atteints ça a pris
quatre mois pour perdre le 25 livres de
masse adipeuse d'être dans une forme où
j'étais quand j'avais 20 ans il
s'efforce de maintenir son alimentation
c'est eugène gérer introduit des fruits
mais tout ce qui est dessus de
transformation des serres hle beaucoup
beaucoup moins peut-être une fois par
semaine pendant les vendanges du coeur
on a le droit à un tout aussi par
semaine donc on seul permet ça fait du
bien on apprécie puis je bois pas
d'alcool donc ce soir qui essayait ce
temps le plus pour moi dans le fonds
serait ce que cinq défis pareil
[Musique]